universities have had their share of
headlines recently from allegations of
chinese influence renaming colleges
following donations no platforming of
speakers controversies over trans rights
and kathleen stock the professor at
sussex university
now oxford university finds itself at
the heart of the latest storm over
donations of more than 12 million pounds
from the mosley family trust which
inherited a fortune from the british
union of fascists leader sir oswald
mosley
and the storm is growing with fresh
revelations in the telegraph today that
both imperial college london and
university college london accepted
millions more from the trust
a senior oxford don now says the
university has lost its moral compass
and the government needs to act to
reform the whole sector he's professor
lawrence goldman emeritus professor at
saint peter's college he joins me
now
writing on the telegraph uh
professor goldman you say our
universities have lost their way and
need the charity commission and
government to intervene
decisively um
what exactly is the problem with max
mosley's money
well the problem is max mosley himself
and his relationship to the history of
british fascism um people might think of
him as a colorful character in british
public life he died in may of this year
somebody involved in motor racing but as
a young man having graduated from oxford
uh he joined his father's second attempt
at forming a fascist movement in the
late 1950s and early 1960s and he went
around terrorizing and intimidating
people on the streets of notting hill in
west london and on the streets of
dalston in east london
and he never apologized he was never
willing to atone for those crimes and
sins and in his autobiography he makes
it plain that he didn't think he he
actually um did do anything wrong that
was published in 2015 so it was very
surprising after further revelations
about the person that he was in the
press and in broadcasting media in 2018
that the university of oxford should
continue to take money from the mosley
family trust which he chaired up to his
death this year
yeah but um
your college saint peter's college uh
says
that whatever
the source of the money it will be
transformative for students
it is a lot of money and perhaps it will
benefit from some students one of the
other colleges says the mostly money uh
will benefit what they call diverse
students by which i think they mean
minority or poor students
yeah well i i understand that and that
argument is always used in circumstances
like this but don't you think actually
that that money should go to the
communities who were terrorized uh and
beaten up by mosley and his thugs twice
in the 20th century in the 1930s and the
early 1960s if the mosley family trusts
want to atone if they want to do good in
the world surely they should be building
civic centers in notting hill or old age
homes for elderly jews who were beaten
up in golda's green and northwest london
isn't that really the way the money
should be used oxford has lots of money
and can continue to get money from other
sources it does all the time
and i don't really buy the argument that
because you can do some good in oxford
you should just continue to hold on to
what is essentially tainted and dirty
money
but
it might be said the best repost to um
as it were fascist money let's call it
that is to use it to support the the
victims of fascism or the the people
that fascists would like to see expunged
from universities
yeah absolutely i completely agree i
have nothing against helping the
students of saint peter's i spent my
career helping the students of saint
peter's but they're not really the
people who should be the worthy
recipients of these funds what should
have happened was that long ago max
mosley should have apologized for his
actions he should have fessed up to what
he has done and then he should have used
that money very productively uh to
assist those who were as it were on the
receiving end the victims of that
fascist violence and then also if he
wished to he could have supported uh uh
colleges in oxford and the university uh
nothing against people apologizing and
atoning for their sins and then using
their money productively but without
that apology i don't really think this
money belongs in oxford oxford should
live by it its professions uh its values
it its academic integrity and it should
reject funds like this which are still
tainted
you accused oxford of losing its moral
compass and uh much as those of us who
are graduates of other universities
would like uh all wickedness to
to reside in oxford and indeed cambridge
it is true that other universities
london school of economics a university
college and indeed my own alma mater
imperial college have got mostly money
are you saying that all of them and the
sector as a whole is losing its moral
compass that's a big claim
well i suspect i am i wasn't aware of
the degree to which this money had been
spread across the system but you do have
to ask how it can be that so many of our
leading uh universities seem not to
recognize the significance of the name
of mosley when donations are put in in
front of them seem not to recognize that
there are many communities in britain
and around the world who will feel
insulted that this money is being used
by the universities without an apology
uh so i do think there is a broad
problem the university sector has to be
much more careful
so in short you're saying give it back
and if they don't give it back
would you um ask mr zahawi the education
secretary to step in and make sure that
it is handed back and the taint is
removed
yes i'm a historian and i know although
this may seem arcane to your viewers
that in the mid and late 19th century
oxford and cambridge had to be reformed
by the state there were a succession of
royal commissions uh the problems of
non-functioning universities as they
were then were reformed and they were
turned into great powerhouses of
research and teaching and development
that we've come to know and admire and i
do think there's a role for the state i
i believe in self-governance i believe
these universities should largely be
self-governing but if they can't govern
themselves effectively and according to
the moral principles that i think most
british people would expect of great
universities then there may be a role
for the state indeed
okay professor goldman thank you very
much indeed
thank you